bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got
annabelle here thank you so much for
doing this
bars thanks for having me for sure uh
you are sitting on the other side of the
world
in china right now um and you've had a
very kind of unique background that you
worked in the legacy world and now
working crypto
walk us through just where did you grow
up how did you get into finance
originally and then why
transition to a crypto industry sure
so hi everyone my name is annabelle hong
and i'm a partner at amber group
so a little bit about my background i
was born and raised in china
then went to the states for college so i
went to carnegie mellon and studied math
and finance
and you know just went into the
traditional finance world because that
was what makes the most sense given my
background and
um and then i did effect structuring
in new york uh for deutsche bank and
then adamura
for a number of years and that really
gave me insight into how traditional
markets work
um and in fx um you know the trading
style
and um got to know a lot of the top
institutional clients
on the back of it as well but after a
few years i just
felt like you know maybe you know i
could
spend another 10 years being on the same
trading floor doing kind of similar
deals
um but what else or where is growth
and i've always been interested in
crypto or
bitcoin actually um from when i was in
college a lot of my computer science
friends were telling me oh my gosh look
at this new
distributed system and you know crypt
on the crypto side and i took a look at
the
white paper and i was more interested in
the
i guess in the new way that economics
could work
uh in a decentralized fashion and
the game theory behind it uh behind a
consensus mechanism that enabled a truly
trustless system for everybody in the
world to participate
in so i thought that was really genius
but never really considered as a
full-time career until
2018 when a few of my carnegie mellon
alums reached out so they were building
a decentralized exchange on ethereum
and they were working with consensus
it's called airswap it's a
decentralized peer-to-peer trading venue
and you know i really liked
the team and uh and joined them moved to
asia moved to hong kong
to lead asia extension for them and
really approached crypto from more of a
um layer two protocol or more of a
technology and product point of view
as opposed to i see a lot of my peers in
finance
traditional finance who moved to crypto
um mostly trading
bitcoin or you know other crypto as an
asset class and didn't really get to
know
the underlying technology
behind it and i really see
defy or blockchain as the
you know that it really revolutionized
finance and technology
as we know it so that was really
exciting for me and
um you know really decided to to go into
it full-time
and after spending a year um in in d5
world
and that was back in 2018 where nothing
like what we saw last year in 2020.
um so the user experience is poor
because the online tech is still
quite nascent and there's no really
liquidity anywhere
um so i decided to join amber
which is a crypto finance company based
in hong kong
and it's really more of a global
platform being at both the intersection
of
d5 and c5 so you really get to see a lot
more market activity
got to serve as more clients from there
and i really clicked with just with the
amber co-founders
we all had really similar backgrounds um
born and raised in china
went to school in the states or the uk
uh worked on wall street for a few years
and then really just saw
crypto for its potential and that's why
and we all pivoted to crypto full-time
yeah i love it and so when you think
about amber group today what does the
product suite look like and kind of what
are you guys trying to accomplish
right so everywhere was started in 2017
and there was a bunch of um you know fx
traders
et cetera on wall street and when we
started it was initially just a a
sells and trading style desk where we
have traders on the desk everything
we're servicing
um we're servicing our institutional
clients offline through our you know
traders and and in 2019 that was about
almost three years of servicing um high
now with individuals and
institutional clients in space and
that's when we realized that we really
saw the need to digitize
and platformize a lot of our offerings
because people are used to
you know maybe making a trade on a
website or on their phone
so um that's when we built our first
product
uh called amber pro which is a webin
portal
and then it offers trading functions
uh as well as some time deposit
so where you can earn on your collateral
as well
and in 2020 that's when we
launched our second product the amber
app which is a mobile app that's easier
to use
more designed for people needed a space
um
that's also when we saw a influx
of actually both institutional and
retail investors from the traditional
space come into
crypto on the back of this amazing rally
um so yeah with our product suite
whether the website or our trading desk
offline or our amber app
really aim to serve a various a variety
of uh clients um maybe they're new or
maybe they're more like crypto og so
whoever they can find um something
that's relevant for them and we aim to
be the gateway
to crypto finance for more people
to come to the space um and because we
really believe in it we believe that
people
more users can really capture long-term
value
from the world of crypto finance
absolutely
so you're based now in in asia um
maybe talk a little bit about what is
the crypto scene like in
asia uh what is kind of different than
the united states what is similar to
uh the united states or north america uh
when you think of those two different
geographies
yeah it is quite interesting um so i
first
got involved in crypto in in new york
and then it was very um it's a very
different crowd than what you see here
in hong kong and the rest of
asia um i would say in new york
or in the us in general i think people
are
a lot of projects they're focused more
on r d
um building out different techs we see
um
even with last year the whole d5 boom
right most of the innovation are coming
from
from the states um and then there are
people building different
um different chains out there and
different blockchains out there other
than
ethereum versus in in asia
or i guess and in china first of all
it's very
casual business driven so you see a lot
of exchanges based
in asia a lot of minors um
and a lot of training shops just because
i guess those are the more
you know readily cash flow driven
businesses
um but one thing i i do feel
you know the biggest difference is it's
just the the sentiment
and the drive of people like i think
in the states um just because there are
a lot of regulatory constraints
and concerns people sometimes are more
hesitant towards driving business
forward
but in asia i think people are more
eager to you know to test things out to
get things going underground
so we do see um you know a lot of
early adopters coming from asia maybe
the tech came from the states but i
think a lot of people are
more eager to participate in the
ecosystem
from from asia so that i think it's a
great combination
i i think again taking
d5 as an example last year a lot of the
liquidity mining
programs or yield farming programs um
i think it is driven from innovation uh
from the states but we see a lot of
participants
from asian that really brought the
ecosystem about a community
forward so so yeah it's quite
interesting um
to see that dynamic for sure and so when
you think through
um in the asian market specifically it
what is the advantage
is it a certain type of regulatory
regime is it a certain type of founder
maybe is it some sort of cultural
kind of framework or experience that
people have as to why there's certain
types of
projects and and kind of innovations
that happen in asia versus north america
is there any kind of uh answer to like
why is it different
um i think i think mentality culturally
maybe i think
um i think we we see in asia
i guess in korea and japan it is hard
for people to find yield anywhere
especially like i guess in japan right
all the yields are negative and
i think people are perhaps more inclined
to find the
opportunities and more um acceptable to
new
new things um so that's why i think the
crypto adoption in korea and japan
um are among the highest in the world
and i think in china just because um we
have
seen a incredible decade
of the booming and internet product
itself so i think a lot of people are
leveraging that experience right from
um you know the tencent alibaba's etc
and leveraging that um and applying it
to crypto to build
um more products like exchanges or
wallets or more crypto finance
service servicing apps so i think
you do see you do see that i think first
of all people are more eager
to to do things more they're they're
more open to accept new things
um and i think regulatory
constraints definitely play a role um
you see
you see with japan right they they were
really active
in crypto and now with more stringent
regular
um regulatory uh requirements in place
i think that activity has since um
you know died down a little bit
um but i think everybody obviously in
asia
are still cognizant of the regulatory
requirements
but i think they're just more willing to
test out new things
absolutely and so when you look at the
user base uh
in asia it feels like um there's a
massive advantage in terms of just the
digital economy already right whether it
was gaming or other pieces to it
um forget crypto for a second like help
people understand like what else is
going on in the digital economy
uh in these asian regions that
give people kind of a a predisposition
to something like crypto and maybe a
little bit more trust a little bit more
open-mindedness
yeah for sure and i think um
first of all i think within asia and
china is leading this whole
growth right that we skipped the whole
desktop
phase and went straight to smartphones
she went straight to mobile
so everybody here has a mobile phone
smartphone
um you i don't carry physical cash with
me anymore
everywhere i go you scan a qr code and
you pay and you transfer
all digitally and
it's quite interesting actually when i
first
returned to asia and i didn't even have
my alipay or wechat pay set up and
i was trying to just pay my cab and then
he
didn't want to accept my cash and said
you know i just just go
and i felt like wow they just really
don't
you know the whole um the user behavior
here is so different now um just you
know on the back of the whole smartphone
and the pro
internet product development and
and that perhaps give people um
like you said very much more just
position into using
things that are digital and people buy
things online now everything is done
through mobile apps
um every little thing and i think
payment is
perhaps the most different because in
the states
people still pay with their credit cards
and all that but here you know there's
no cards no physical
cash it's all done on the app and
the chinese government is also pushing
out um digital currency right we call it
dsap
um and there they have run trials
in shenzhen and now in beijing um
pushing out um on a national
scale um government scale that you know
everybody should just use
e c and y um so that is that would be
quite interesting to see
absolutely and so when you think through
those digital payments
uh is that actually a hurdle for crypto
adoption in terms of
uh what's the difference between
spending the digital
um currency via like an alipay or
something like that
what's the difference between let's say
the chinese government's uh
kind of digital central bank currency uh
or crypto like those three things the
user experience seems pretty similar
it's actually like this underpinning
technology that may be different
um and who controls it was it
centralized decentralized
um so is that like a benefit and a
tailwind uh for crypto adoption or is
that actually a headwind and potentially
an obstacle in your opinion that's a
that's a great question or i think i
think it is
a bit of both ways so first of all um
with the central banks of the government
pushing out digital currency and digital
assets in general i think that
definitely
bring people's attention to what digital
assets
are what it means how do i use a wallet
how do i you know transact um
because dsap the underlying tech is
still blockchain
although it is arguably very very
different from from crypto
um as we know it just because right one
is
extremely centralized and one is the
opposite
um so i think it is good in terms of
user education
um to a certain extent and then i think
people
are going to start realizing that um now
if dsep truly eliminated
cash then every transaction everything
they do
will be recorded somewhere and
you know and that might prompt people to
think about
decentralization or you know having some
sort of
privacy even though the expectation the
level expectations
um of privacy in china and and
the states or rest of world is perhaps a
little different
but i think it will get people to start
thinking um
about about what that all means so i
think it is not going to immediate
um headwind but but we but we shall see
um
and i think people here are looking into
bitcoin as
more for alternative ass and investment
um and import and opportunity for yield
as well
um so less so on the kind of
decentralization
aspect yet but we have seen a lot of
um family offices and china with
individuals
looking to bitcoin as either
inflation hedge or store of wealth or
you know
just um another portfolio of
diversification to add
and the case for it is so strong that
nobody can ignore it
and you know we've seen just every day
their their new institutions coming out
saying they're backing bitcoin right
like i think yesterday was
blackrock and and who knows who's going
to come out today and tomorrow
so i think that everyone is definitely
paying attention to crypto
um on its own and then maybe just
just curious about how um digital
currency will work
yeah and so when you think through uh
the adopters of this there's obviously
the institutional world and then there's
the retail world
i know you guys have a ton of
institutional clients talk a little bit
about
um kind of what you're hearing from that
crowd as we see
uh the prices of the liquid assets go up
and many of these businesses do pretty
well
yeah um i think on the institutional
side
um most of our clients um
they are of the view that they're
they're holding at least bitcoin
further for the long run and um given
it's a broad
bull market so a lot of people who are
investing in d5 etc
um has been um benefiting
a lot from it this year so everyone is
quite active so trading bitcoin and some
d5 coins on top of it that's what we've
seen
mostly and there are
new money coming in every day from
traditional finance space so i guess the
institutions in the traditional sense
um and they're mostly looking to to
purchase bitcoin
um to add to their portfolios
and i think on the retail side
um every as we've seen where there's
records signups for finance and coinbase
and
our own platform has also seen an
increase in the user signups i think
they're definitely
paying attention and um and
looking to get into space as well i
think just that the whole
market sentiment um first of all it
feels a lot
more healthier like a lot healthier than
what transpired in 2017 i would say
um but this growth this rally again
is incredible so we feel really good
about this year
and hopefully we will see more people
uh accepting bitcoin um
and coming to the space absolutely
what's been the biggest surprise for you
over the last you know call it year or
so as we saw this public health crisis
throughout the globe
uh we saw governments elected officials
step in with you know incredible amount
of monetary stimulus
um you're literally on the other side of
the world i think i've talked way too
much and
basically bored the hell out of people
here of what's going on in the united
states but uh
how has that been in the last year
what's been most surprising
uh in asia well yeah it's completely
um i don't even know where to start just
seeing where
the states you know i spent almost a
decade in
in the u.s so i i felt like it was my
second home and it was really
um quite devastating to to see it become
like this and
whereas i guess where the outbreak
started
is actually my hometown so my parents
are from muhan
and i was almost on my way to go back
there for
chinese new year last year so again
right that's also my home base i felt
like just
um quite um sad to
see the world like this last year and
but you can see
the the level of centralized
governmental control
um here in china and
just putting everything in place
immediately
muhan was shut down from jan 23rd until
april 8th everyone stayed at home
for the rest of the metropolitans in
china we all stayed at home for at least
um a month i think and then
and then you know everybody reacted
really fast um and then
got got the situation under control
and within china we're basically free to
travel
we were free to travel since may last
year
pretty much so it's been a it's been
normal for us for
for almost a year now um you know that i
think i remember in february and march
um a lot of my friends in new york were
just like i just
should come back which i'm glad i didn't
and um and then you just compare
the the level you know the the policies
and
procedures that different governments
put out um
you compare that and you see where we
are now
um you know i i don't want to comment
further
on on that but um but
but yeah it's definitely um different
worlds uh um very different
um here versus the states
for sure um when you kind of talk to
your friends in the united states
uh is there anything that really sticks
out to you as
maybe what crypto investors believe in
the western world that you see as a
being in direct contrast to what's going
on in the east and not so much what's
being built
or how it's being adopted but just are
there philosophical differences
are there uh kind of mindset differences
maybe there's even like the
perspectives of the world in terms of
the west believes that you know bitcoin
is going to be this
successful thing and the east thing
something else is there anything that
jumps to mind as to what's the
contrasting
uh kind of mental frameworks people use
in the different regions
i would think the underlying rational
feels quite universal across the globe
um people believe in bitcoin
um for you know ads as a store of value
as um store value that's better than
gold perhaps and
um people especially the younger
generation likes the idea
of a complete new asset class and
um so i think that on that level
it is quite universal but i do think
people
perhaps approach it from from slightly
different
um aspects of it people in the western
world
they value decentralization um more
i actually like to compare
decentralization with
privacy um it's not a necessity people
don't need it but
um but for some people right it is
really important and
they really value it i think that that
concept is perhaps a little weaker here
in in asia or in china so i think people
still approach it from more of a
financial
um you know or yield opportunity
versus and in the states perhaps people
really believe
more so and its design and its original
vision
um etc but i i do think um
people are are investing in it um be a
retail
institutions being be it um
the western world or asia they all have
um people really are believing in
bitcoin and i i do think that we have
found market validation for that
narrative absolutely uh what's the thing
you're most excited about in the crypto
industry right now
it's just just so much i think every day
um you wake up to see um
a different price level you know news
from
um more um just traditional heavyweights
coming into space and and
um kind of and telling you that you were
right
all this time i think a lot of people
did a 180
different banks or different asset
managers
um who really dismissed the idea
of our innovative new asset class
maybe three or four years ago right i
and it's just really incredible to see
that and i think there's still
a really long way to go and that's what
really excites me
um some people ask me you know where do
you think is going to be the big thing
in five years and
i really believe it's going to be
something that we haven't seen yet today
right just the speed of innovation
um you we i don't even know what's going
to come
out of the space in a month's time let
alone five years
um i think that's what really drives us
to
continue to be innovative in this space
to adapt to the newest market trends to
give
users what they want um and to really
grow
with the industry absolutely
before i let you go i just asked
everyone the same three questions uh the
first is what is the most important book
that you've ever read
that's um that's a great question um
i grew up reading a lot of uh literature
i guess chinese ones and after i learn
english english ones as well
um but i i'll throw a book that i really
liked and i've read a couple times
it's called fortunes formula it is about
a bunch of mathematicians and and people
working on information
systems information theories and
and then trying to game the casino so to
speak
by playing back blackjack counting cards
etc it's a really fun story but i think
most importantly
uh it is about trading um
it talks about the likes of john kelly
um
kelly criterion this um
it really taught me how to size my bets
um either on you know sports betting or
trading in general and then talks about
at thorpe
which is a len you know a legend um
and who is a mathematician and turned
into
basically um discovered or approved
black shells by himself
on you know equity options pricing and
then
started his own hedge fund and made
incredible returns over the years
so it's a great story um that
married um mathematicians
and to the finance world and there's
some like
mafia and casino games behind it so it's
a great
from review it so you know recommend
everybody to take a read
nobody's recommended that one before
that's a great suggestion
uh probably the math uh nerd of me who
likes that
i love it uh second question is about
sleep uh comes from our friends over at
eight sleep they've got a
thermo-regulated bed that essentially
you can make it really hot or really
cold
uh i used to sleep like six or seven
hours or really five or six hours
um and then i started sleeping on it i
sleep on it like it's ice cold
uh literally uh you know as cold as you
can basically make it
and uh sip like a baby now eight nine
hours a night i am a
full-on convert to the sleep religion uh
what is your sleep schedule do you use
any sort of uh
sleep products or aids or anything
i think i'm blessed in the way that um
i just passed out and i need six hours
of sleep and i'm
good to go kind of so yay um
but um i i do like code therapy actually
so the another book i was gonna
mention was called uh what doesn't kill
you uh make make you stronger in a sense
and it
talks about breathing exercise and
co-therapy
that triggers a lot of the revolutionary
strength that we had
but lost because we use technology to
make our lives so comfortable
right we cannot endure heat or cold
anymore
um we you know we're always full
actually we have
excess like energy intake every day and
um that book really
walks you through how you can trigger a
lot of that um
strength that that better your immune
system and and get
better sleep um and just better energy
level actually
so um i sleep well and perhaps due to
the co-therapy or other things or you
know exercise
um but you know i want to check out that
um
that that thermal badge i used to do
cryotherapy
in new york in new york but i don't
really see that um
anymore in asia but i really liked it as
well
yeah ate sleep they are fantastic i
highly i don't know if they shipped to
china but uh but they are fantastic
uh third question is a little bit more
fun and you'll get to ask me one to
finish up
uh aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
believer um i guess from uh statistic
you know statistics point of view right
there are so many galaxies planted stars
um it is unlikely that we don't we don't
see another
um i guess form of life or aliens
um and in that sense but um
but i not sure like if
actually going back to the book question
there's another book that i would also
recommend here it's called three bodies
it's actually written by um i'm sure
you've
read it right it's uh written by a
chinese author
one of the best sci-fi books i've read
and the dark forest theory
um it is uh from a game three point of
view right i think if there are aliens
either you know they're a lower form of
like lower intelligence and we found
them and you know we'll
if we're going to you know annihilate
that
or one day someone who's with higher
intelligence is going to discover us
then i guess well
that's the end for us um but i do
believe in in the dark
forest um theory we actually see that
within d5 and in the
d5 gas war so that's also an interesting
detour but yeah that's
that's my answer to the question i love
it
i'm i'm a believer too so i hear you uh
you could ask me one question to finish
up what do you got for me
um so so many actually i guess you know
you've been
in this space and you've been the
bitcoin believer
for um you know one of the biggest
advocates we've seen the space
there's still one question back at you
right what what excites you
the most what gets you going
i think that we are all drastically
underestimating how important it is
that uh these wall street institutions
are showing up
um and i don't look at it from like
i'm cheering on the financialization of
bitcoin specifically
as much as it is uh the more that these
financial institutions say we like
bitcoin we want to hold bitcoin
the less likely nation-state attacks
against bitcoin will be
um and so i think that in some weird way
wall street is protecting bitcoin
um over uh over time and so i think
that's a really really
you know kind of fascinating way to uh
to think through
uh the game theory on a global basis you
know does this thing survive
and i tend to be an optimist i tend to
agree that uh
you know bitcoin will end up kind of
ascending to global reserve status
uh over a period of time which is uh
pretty cool to think about and watch
yeah awesome i agree i figured you did i
figured you did
um all right andrew where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
or find out more about what you guys are
building
sure you can um find more information
about amber group and our product suite
on ambergroup.io our website
you can follow us on twitter at amber
group underscore
io you can follow me on twitter as well
at
underscore annabel huang we're on medium
we're on
telegram um or on the website email us
drop us a note awesome listen thank you
so much for doing this let's do it
together future
thanks for having me again it's great
chatting with you